Welcome back everyone Happy New Year Marvel just
revealed how it's setting up the new version of
Wolverine after Hugh Jackman during Captain
America 4 New World Order in the Thunderbolts
movie and it turns out they're using the eternals
movie to explain it there are a few theories it
confirms and a few surprises so we'll break it
all down because in addition to Marvel bringing
back a bunch of the Legacy Fox Marvel X-Men
characters like Deadpool Patrick Stewart as
variant of Professor X Hugh Jackman Wolverine
they're also in the middle of explaining how
new versions of the characters start appearing
in the mate 616 Marvel Universe played by new
actors that was the whole reason why they played
the X-Men the Animated Series theme song during
the Miss Marvel series like oh we're going to
start seeing more mutants and X-Men characters
showing up really soon so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's a bunch of big trailers coming
really soon Ant-Man and the Wasp quantumania
because of the new year more secret Invasion
more Loki season 2 footage but new X-Men in
the MCU you may have seen some of the reports in
your feeds about everything Marvel's doing with
Captain America 4 in the Thunderbolts movie
there's so much stuff happening in those two
movies because they're happening at the end of
Marvel phase five they're intended to be like
many Avengers movies pushing the overarching
plot into Marvel phase six so there's a bunch
of characters a bunch of really cool Concepts
they're introducing through those two movies
Marvel's new versions of the X-Men characters
are slowly starting to show up along with mutants
we've already seen a couple of them so far like
not core X-Men characters yet but we have seen
a few mutants like Miss Marvel and Namor recently
Kevin feige did say that that would continue more
would start showing up in Marvel Phase 5 but like
the new Big X-Men team with mostly new actors new
versions of the characters would take a little
bit longer like the new X-Men movie that they're
working on isn't currently listed for Marvel
phase six so they might be waiting till after
Avengers 6 Secret Wars to do it like Marvel phase
7 is the beginning of a huge X-Men era in the MCU
Hugh Jackman coming back is his Wolverine
Deadpool showing up the other Legacy actors
having cameos is just meant to be a temporary
thing until the new X-Men debut eventually in
Marvel just confirmed that one of the ways
they're introducing those new core X-Men in
the MCU Wolverine specifically a wolverine who's
not played by Hugh Jackman is during Captain
America 4 and the Thunderbolts movie Marvel's
introducing the concept of adamantium using the
events of the eternals movie as a catalyst you
remember what we were looking for it helped us
create a metal compound so strong that you
will be able to withstand virtually anything
it's called adamantium they're finally going to
do something with a giant Stone Celestial that's
stuck out of the Indian Ocean that they haven't
referenced that many times you think that more
people in the MC would be yelling about that
in the movies why is there a giant Stone man
sticking out of the ocean like they had a joke
in She-Hulk but that's really the only reference
that we've had since the eternals movie Marvel's
changing a little bit of the adamantium storyline
in the way that it was created but they're
using a couple comic book plots they're saying
the team its Celestial body is partially made
of adamantium ore or through his creation he
created adamantium not his entire body like his
entire body would be indestructible if that was
the case but celestials can form their bodies out
of whatever minerals they have available to them
and you have to imagine that they get sent to all
kinds of different planets so they have different
materials available to them wherever they wind
up going really good example of this is that
some celestials use vibranium when growing their
bodies when they find it on different planets
but it's super rare so it's not like every single
Celestial has vibranium in their bodies they have
a set of tmit as the first Celestial whose body is
made of adamantium or if all celestials are like
this probably not just because vibranium like I
said is so rare and adamantium is basically a form
of synthetic vibranium in the comics adamantium
was created by the United States scientists who
were attempting to create artificial vibranium
after black panther wouldn't let them have it
we literally just saw that storyline play out
in Black Panther wakanda forever as the United
Nations with raimonda taking them to task because
all the other world Nations Thunderbolt Ross Val
everybody wanted their vibranium some were trying
to take it by force during the movie Val even
specifically told Everett Ross that she dreamed
of the day when America controls all the world's
vibranium and initially a lot of us just assume
that was meant to be a teaser for Captain America
4 the Thunderbolts movie and she would actually
move on that plan and try to use her power to
steal some of that vibranium with the Thunderbolts
team turns out we were partially correct because
there's an extra twist to that Valen Thunderbolt
Ross learned about the adamantium on the Celeste
steel body and it turns into a race to claim it
like the entire world all nations good people
bad people all want to race to claim all these
adamantium and Celestial resources on his body you
have to imagine that even without the adamantium
he's still a treasure Trove of cosmic energy just
brimming out of that Celestial body so anybody
with half a brain would try to claim it to either
weaponize it or monetize it in some way it's just
so valuable you actually see something like this
going on during the Guardians of the Galaxy movie
because that's why the collector purchased nowhere
the head of the Dead Celestial to mine it for
all of its Cosmic resources which is where we
get to the evolution of the weapons plus program
which Marvel has already canonized in the MCU
during The Incredible Hulk movie in Marvel
phase one during that movie Thunderbolt Ross
specifically mentions that he called the program
the weapons plus program he says I pulled it out
of mothballs it was basically an evolution
of the super soldier program you're aware
that we've got an infantry weapons development
program well in WW2 they initiated a sub program
for biotech Force enhancement super soldier an
oversimplification but yes and I dusted it off
got him doing serious work again bold work
across the hauler trying to arm you better
and we're trying to make you better each new
person who goes through the weapons plus program
is given a number of designation so Captain
America for example is weapon one Wolverine
is weapon 10 when we say Weapon X the weapon x is
Roman numeral he's weapon number 10 and in the MCU
they can't create a new MCU version of Wolverine
without adamantium for a skeleton and it turns out
this is where they get it now that being said Hugh
Jackman will debut as his Wolverine in the MCU in
Deadpool 3 before this brand new Wolverine shows
up in the MCU with a different actor just to give
you a sense of the timeline on some of these
new X-Men characters debuting it's like we're
just seeing them form the next iteration the
weapons plus program then eventually the next
Wolverine spins out of that but you can see how
they're using valve to set a lot of this stuff up
particularly the weapons plus that program is also
supposed to be how Val creates the Sentry because
the Sentry is also part of the weapons plus
program the golden Sentry formula that gives him
his powers is essentially like a new iteration of
the super soldier serum I've already done a miss
larger video on the Sentry character so I'll
post links down in the description below and
at the end of this but he's kind of like Marvel's
version of Superman or homelander homelander is a
better example because he seems like he's totally
crazy and because they both got their powers from
taking his serum tell me the real reason I want
to hear you say it tired I want them to love me
and now I'll get us through this just as long as
you and me stick together during the MCU though
the whole idea is that by the Thunderbolts movie
when Sentry debuts for the first time he's going
to be like one of the main villains in that movie
he starts to hear the voices in his head of his
other evil self it drives him crazy and Val uses
the Thunderbolts to clean up her mess because
she was the person who created Sentry in the
first place it's sort of like Marvel doing their
version of what the boys did during season three
with them pulling soldier boy out of mothballs
to try and take down homelander like okay our
super powerful character here has gone crazy we
need to stop him at any cost Captain America 4
is also supposed to be the movie where the new
Falcon Captain America starts to assemble his
new Avengers team it'll be a combination of the
Avengers who survived Avengers end game and some
of the new characters who showed up during Marvel
phase 4 the xiangxi post credit scene is a really
good example of that the other really big stuff
that they're doing in Captain America 4 are the
debut of Harrison Ford as the recast version of
Thunderbolt Ross Marvel recast the character after
William Hurt passed away recently normally they
would just stop using the character the reason
why they recast Thunderbolt Ross with such a huge
actor is because during Captain America 4 they
want Thunderbolt Ross to become the president
of the United States and the Red Hulk it is meant
to be part of a larger dark rain storyline across
Marvel Phase 5 starting with a secret Invasion
series which is kind of how things played out in
the comics it's just they're giving some of the
Norman Osborne storyline from those comic book
storylines to Thunderbolt Ross and Val after Nick
Fury stops the evil Scrolls in secret Invasion
from destroying the planet completely taking over
all the world governments Valen Thunderbolt Ross
basically take credit for everything that he
did and ride that wave to even more political
power to win the presidency but right now as a
black panther will counter forever Val's already
director of the CAA she is already very powerful
the whole twist with the Red Hulk is them paying
off the Bruce Banner Hulk versus Thunderbolt Ross
storyline that's been going on since the first
Incredible Hulk movie in Marvel phase one God damn
it I want what's inside of him finally being able
to steal the gamma powers of the Hulk they kind
of did a jokey funny version of that during the
She-Hulk series with the Todd character in The
Intelligentsia the connection here is that in
the comics it was actually the Intelligentsia that
gave Thunderbolt Ross the powers of the Red Hulk
but because they already used that organization as
a joke in She-Hulk obviously there's going to be
a different explanation during Captain America 4.
that's also what that whole teaser for scar son of
Hulk was at the end of She-Hulk that was meant to
set up the big twist with red Hulk during Captain
America 4. in part of a larger World War Hulk
storyline that they're doing across the Marvel
movies like I said there's like a billion things
that are happening in these two movies Captain
America four in the Thunderbolts movie but
that's because they're meant to be the end
of Marvel phase five like many Avengers movies and
they want this big push into Marvel phase six and
this really WTF kind of way but everyone let me
know in the comments who do you want to play this
new Wolverine after Hugh Jackman has his Cameo
scenes he will be back during Avengers 6 Secret
Wars but they're just meant to be temporary things
so seems like a whole bunch of characters are
coming back to Marvel you can click here to learn
about Robert Downey Jr coming back as Iron Man
in new movies confirming a bunch of theories and
click here to learn about Ben Affleck coming back
as a new Marvel character thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy New Year!